I've been feeling like I need to add juiced or blending to my diet to get no revenge to this down.
When I got my genetics tested done, I learned that my body does not
do a good job converting beta-carotene to vitamin A.
Does this mean I should limit carrots in my juiced and blending?
No, it doesn't.
Matter of fact, it would need that.
So the conversion process, when you have that, I think it's a BCMO gene defect.
You have a more difficult time with vitamin A and converting beta-carotene to your active level of vitamin A.
So one line of thought is that you should take more beta-carotene because then you'll end up with more converted usable vitamin A in your body.
So I would kind of hold to that.
So I don't think you need to limit carrots, so you're juiced and going to do.
The only thing I would say about juiced and blending is that you have to have a healthy gut to do that.
If you have a leaky gut issue, juicing and blending is raw.
So that, you know, we talked about this before, and I have blog posts on this too, that, you know, these practitioners that say, you have cancer, everything you should go to a raw food diet.
That is just not true.
The food diet can be really hard on your gut.
Even if it's juiced or blended, you're just pre-digested.
It's still hard to absorb those things.
It can still be irritated to the gut wall.
So if you have a lot of intestinal permeability, aka a leaky gut syndrome, a raw food diet can be hard on it.
And you know, the adage of cooking your vegetables, you destroy all the nutrients and your vegetables.
That's only a partial truth.
The gap's diet, which we use to the past for all our ADD, ADHD, fibrobalgia, autoimmune patients, was beneficial.
And it worked.
And the reason why it works is because you're breaking down the cell, a wall of the, the, of the plan so that they're more easily digested.
So it does take a lot of pressure.
So you're getting more of the nutrients out of them, so that you are able to absorb the nutrients, especially if you're cooking in a soup.
So if you're making soup, so we used to get these people on a gap's diet or reading bone broth.
And once they've been up in a bone broth, you don't want to do that necessarily interpretation.
Or when they're eating bone broth, you have high end ingredients that helps heal the gut.
Lighting, then you're getting them just eating soups, so they're vegetables in the bone broth.
And now you're getting nutrients to help heal the gut in your, you know, raw form.
It's too irritating on the gut. So these people that have leaky gut issues, intestinal permeability issues, already inflammatory issues.
It can be hard on your gut to have raw foods.
You're much more susceptible to the protein in your off foods as well to develop antibodies against.
So remember, if you have a leaky gut, you have a greater chance of developing antibodies to different peptides, aka proteins in different foods.
That's why we advocate towards using Syrex 10 panop because it tests for many of these common food sensitivities in both cooked and raw foods,
because the protein is different in whether it's cooked or it's raw.
So, something to consider the least.